und was macht man mit einem
freundschaftsdenkmal zwischen Russland
und der Ukraine in Zeiten in denen die
beiden gegeneinander Krieg führen ja es
sollte die Freundschaft zwischen diesen
beiden Ländern betonen finden dieser
Freundschaft ist natürlich nichts mehr
übrig und deswegen passiert jetzt mit
diesem Denkmal genau das erstell zwei
Arbeiter da aus der Ukraine der Kopf
fällt hier ab dem russischen Arbeiter
Kopf ab also und der Bürgermeister Kiews
Vitali Klitschko hat dazu das hier
gesagt
Russland ist in die Ukraine eingefallen
die ersten 30 Raketen fielen in der
Nacht vom 24 Februar auf die Ukraine
können wir mit Russland befreundet sein
was denken Sie dies ist unser
schlimmster Feind das Denkmal zu
russisch ukrainischen Freundschaft macht
keinen Sinn mehr geboren